hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
daten welt ich mache heute einen
weiteren teil meiner grill reihe ich
glaube das ist schon der vierte oder
fünfte teil 2 sich schon gar nicht mehr
genau ich habe schon so viel gekocht und
ich werde heute natürlich ein brot
machen denn so einem schönen grillfest
sondern grillfeier zu selbstgemachten
spießen gehört natürlich auch ein selbst
gemachtes brot
ich hab euch schon letztes jahr ein paar
brote gezeigt zum beispiel könnt ihr
auch meine falten brot machen das geht
superschnell oder zum beispiel auch die
pesto blume bei der pasta blume die
wurde mittlerweile schon über 100.000
mal angeklickt ich habe ganz ganz viele
rückmeldungen bekommen ich bekomme heute
noch so viele fotos geschickt mit dieser
feste blume die ich natürlich immer ein
highlight auf einer party oder auf einem
grillfest auf einem auf einer tafel weil
sie einfach so schön aussieht
ich werde heute allerdings im fladenbrot
machen weil wir ja diese lange spiesse
gemacht haben und ich finde das
fladenbrot da eben perfekte zupass und
das fladenbrot ist eine stand einfach
herzustellen es ist sehr schnell gemacht
es hat eine nachtruhe zeit das heißt ihr
könnt es sehr gut vorbereiten und ich
zeige euch es einfach mal geduld haben
ihr braucht dafür 450 gramm mehl ich
habe jetzt hier ein 550 e mail
dazu sage ich euch gleich aber nochmals
250 milliliter wasser das ist ganz
normal zimmer bei zimmertemperatur also
nicht warm
20 gramm hefe einen teelöffel zucker 2
esslöffel joghurt dass ich jetzt in 35
prozentiger ein teelöffel salz und ich
brauche noch zwei esslöffel olivenöl bei
der mail habe ich jetzt diese 550er mail
genommen ist jetzt auch die sich aus
nach richtigen tollen mühle und zwar
haben wir das zuschauer mitgebracht aus
dem saarland die der andreas und petra
und natürlich die mama war auch da und
da bedanke ich mich noch einmal ganz
herzlich dafür ins super gut gepasst
weil ich eben heute sowieso dieses
fladenbrot machen wollte und ich nehme
es eben dieses 515
weil das bessere backeigenschaften hat
als das normale 405 e mail
natürlich könnt ihr das auch nehmen also
wenn jetzt kein 550 er findet aber
dieses mal hat einfach er den größte
anteil an klebereiweiß also eigentlich
das was die leute mit gluten
unverträglichkeit nicht vertragen und
dadurch wird eben das gebäck lockerer
viel luftiger und deswegen benutze ich
das jetzt eben bei diesem brot dieses
mail könnte auch beim backen brot beim
pesto boot benutzen beim kuchenbacken
also das 550 er hat wirklich bessere
backeigenschaften aber wenn ihr das
nicht habt geht es mit jedem anderen mir
natürlich auch jetzt gebe ich zuerst
mein mädel meine schüsse ich mache das
jetzt in der küchenmaschine ihr könnt
das theoretisch auch per hand machen
dann ist das sehr sehr lange kneten
meine hefe löse ich jetzt kurz in meinem
wasser auf damit sie sich besser im teig
verteilt gibt auch den zucker mit dazu
ich mache es aber keinen vorteil vorteil
würde jetzt bedeuten dass ich jetzt die
hefe mit dem wasser und dem zucker
einfach etwas stehen damit sie schon mal
eben aktiviert wird
damit sie eben aktiviert wird und die
hefezellen sie schneller vermehren und
darauf verzichte ich jetzt aber weil ich
mit dem tag später sehr lange gehen
lassen
die mischung gebe ich da jetzt rein und
lass das jetzt einfach mal verkneten
jetzt gehen schon auf den joghurt mit
dazu
und auch die zwei esslöffel öl und den
teig lass es einfach mal was nähten so
etwa 15 minuten lang einfach damit sich
das klebereiweiß eben lösen kann und der
treibt später richtig schön fluffig wird
steht jetzt noch mal es ist joghurt mir
das wetter zeigt sich nämlich richtig
schön weich sein
es gebe ich noch das salz mit dazu das
ist christ 1 53 minuten lang und damit
halb fertig ich habe meine hände
eingefettet damit sie nicht am tag leben
man könnte nämlich auch ganz einfach
hier den knethaken saubermachen
jetzt habe ich hier einfach den teig
noch am rand runter geht natürlich auch
mit einer tankkarte
ich sehe da klebt echt gar nicht mehr
sorgen
obwohl er so weich ist also so sieht der
fertige teig aus ist seht das richtig
schön weich lebt aber nicht so sehr den
werde ich jetzt mit etwas
frischhaltefolie abdecken und dann eine
nacht im kühlschrank ruhen lassen
da ich es ist einfach wichtig dass sie
in mindestens zwölf stunden im
kühlschrank ruhen lassen damit er schön
aufgehen kann
wir können natürlich auch bis zu 48
stunden einfach liegen lassen im
kühlschrank das heißt man kann den tag
wirklich sehr gut vorbereiten und ich
zeige euch dieses mal ich habe mich
schon vorbereitet so sie daraus er hat
das volumen etwa verdreifacht und ich
zeige euch das mal im vergleich also das
ist die gleiche teilmenge nur eben hier
fordern gehen und hier nach dem gehen
und diesen heiligen tag werde ich jetzt
vorzubereiten zu den pipette den fladen
boten haben einen ofen schonach 230 grad
ober unterhitze vorbereitet stellt den
kurz in den kühlschrank und ansehen
besteht eine arbeitsfläche mit etwas
mehl jetzt kippe ich den teig einfach
auf diese arbeitsfläche bisschen mehr
drüber
ich werde jetzt vier peter draus machen
vier fladenbrote ihr könnt jetzt auch
ein großes oder zwei große machen so
einfach zu erteilen
ich möchte nämlich später hatte ich
spiele gerne rein stecken also ich habe
noch fleischspieße möchtegern dann da
drin haben ich bearbeite den teig auch
nicht so sehr ich drücke ihnen mir jetzt
die form die ich gerne hätte
jetzt habe ich hier meinen vorbereitetes
back ich habe einfach mein normales
pflicht genommen mit der dauer back
folie und setzt es jetzt einfach hörbar
und und dazu verwende ich jetzt einfach
mal den teig retter damit ich da jetzt
nicht so viel dran kaputt mache macht
jetzt doch bisschen länglicher damit sie
besser aufs blech passen
und hier habe ich jetzt ne mischung
vorbereitet und zwar habe ich hier alles
löffel joghurt ein esslöffel milch und
allen esslöffel öl einfach miteinander
vermischt mir das jetzt darauf ganz
genau den den wir auch im teig drin
haben und jetzt könnt ihr diese
typischen muster reinmachen die
fladenbrote eben auch haben und zwar
könnte einfach mit den fingern so rein
drücken müsste aber nicht und jetzt
betreue ist meine peter noch mit sesam
und mit schwarzkümmel schwarzkümmel
kennt er das ich immer aufladen boten
drauf wer das nicht mag kann es auch
weglassen und das mit kräutern oder so
bestreuen
ihr könnt zum beispiel auch etwas
schafskäse oder oliven drauf geben
genau solche erleben getrocknete tomaten
alles was ihr also ganz gerne mögt in
türkischen läden es ist so dass zur
ramadan zeit die kommt es bald da gibt
es auch immer ganz viel fladenbrote und
die gibt es in ganz vielen verschiedenen
sorten als auch mal mit zug zum beispiel
mit dieser türkischen knoblauch wurst
mit schafskäse mit
blieben also das ist alles total lecker
und da könnte alles mögliche benutzen
ich werde jetzt meine peter sofort
weiter backen und zwar werde ich sie
jetzt bei 230 grad so etwa 20 minuten
backen ich schaue einfach mal weil die
heute sehr dünn sind
ich muss ja aber auch so tun haben
möchte und wenn sie schön goldbraun sind
dann nehme ich sie heraus
zeige ich da einfach mal wie ich das
gemeint habe ich habe jetzt hier etwas
käse mit oliven und paprika eingelegt
von fahrt raus war dass ich hole mir
kurz das könnte jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen zerdrücken
und dann habe das so sehr mediterranes
fladenbrot natürlich läuft es da mit den
belegen jetzt auch nicht übertreiben
weil das da das gericht soll ja
eigentlich der am spieß seien aber
dessen video nur über das fladenbrot
deswegen habe ich euch jetzt auch dass
mit diesen käse gezeigt falls ihr zum
beispiel mal einfach zum atmen quoten
fladenbrot machen wollt könnt ihr das
richtig toll belegen und das ist
eigentlich was so ein gericht für sich
noch einen typischen täter zu bisschen
tomaten oliven und dann hat man ein
richtig leckeres abendbrot aber ich
würde jetzt zum grill das fladenbrot
eher neutral halten weil dann einfach
eben der geschmack von fleisch
überwiegend soll und das fladenbrot eher
neutral sein soll
mein bruder sitzt fertig so sieht es
jetzt aus
ich habe es nach dem backen einfach mit
einem tuch abgedeckt und habe etwas
abkühlen lassen
witzig es auch noch schön warm und hier
könnt ihr einfach sehen wie es aussieht
und es ist richtig schön weich und sehr
locker ich glaube ich probiert das jetzt
noch mal probieren meldungen für stück
immer ich hab noch ein tag gemacht nicht
richtig lecker nach fladenbrot wirklich
nichts anderes dazu einfach nur frisches
brot dieses fladenbrot schmeckt
natürlich sehr gut zu meinem getrennten
fleisch aber wie gesagt auch einfach so
zum abendbrot oder mal zum frühstück zum
frühstück ich da auch schnell gemacht
wenn man tag vorher den teig ansatz und
dann am nächsten tag nur noch packt wenn
ihr ein großes macht geht es natürlich
auch höher auf und ihr könnt auch die
fladenbrote noch ein bisschen stehen
lassen damit sie noch mal kurz auf gehen
und dann einfach sofort backen
diese jetzt richtig perfekt zum
durchschneiden und zum fleisch reinlegen
und dieses rasch zu schnell gegessen und
dieses rezept
gibts wie meine anderen rezepte auch auf
sadist orten welt.de und ich geb dir
wasser und wissens beim nächsten mal
wieder bis bald